Rudy Giuliani is saying the quiet part
out loud after all this time spent
arguing that he's not involved in the
Ukraine stuff he didn't interfere they
didn't push anybody out everything was
perfect the phone call was perfect their
relationships with everybody over in
Ukraine the ambassador to everybody else
everything was just perfect Rudy
Giuliani has now admitted to New Yorker
reporter Adam entus that yes he needed
ambassador Murray Ivanovich out of the
way later going last night on Fox News's
Laura Ingraham Ingraham program and
saying I got her out you aren't supposed
to admit this Rudy but you're certainly
making it much easier that's for sure
quote from Adam entus great piece in The
New Yorker Rudy says I believed that I
needed yovanovich out of the way she was
going to make the investigations
difficult for everybody Rudy goes on to
admit that he was working on a dossier
not just about the Biden's but also
about Murray ivanovitch herself and said
let's make this as prominent as possible
by going on TV to talk about it then
last night Rudy went on Fox News and
confirmed this to Laura Ingraham now he
tries to deny that he needed her out of
the way but admits that he forced her
out which is exactly what they've been
denying all this time take a look at
this clip from last night now this hit
piece and it's a hit pieces course also
has you on the record admitting that you
forced out marie ivanovitch did you
needed her out of the way but you're a
personal attorney for the present so why
do you need her out of the way I didn't
need her out of the way I've I forced
her out because she's corrupt so the
alleged hit piece that Laura Ingraham is
referencing is accurate and again Rudy's
trying to make this distinction I didn't
need her out of the way I forced her out
of the way the issue is a non-elected
non senate-confirmed
non-government person who is Donald
Trump's personal lawyer forcing out
ambassadors who are selected by
presidents
this is Red Alert stuff and I know that
in the era of scandal fatigue in the era
of constant drama and Fiasco's and
scandals this stuff gets lost but Rudy
Giuliani is admitting that he as a
non-government actor saw an ambassador
as an impediment to getting what he
wanted and to Donald Trump getting what
he wanted and forced her out he admits
it he's just a lawyer that's all he's
not a government actor this is what they
have been denying all along during the
impeachment hearings one of the main
narratives that remember the Republican
lawyer during the impeachment hearings
was this guy Steve castor and what Steve
castor tried to push was that no one was
trying to push Murray Ivanovich out
everybody was fine with her being the
ambassador Trump wasn't bothered Rudy
wasn't bothered but Trump wanted to root
out corruption and she didn't and all
that stuff here is Rudy admitting he
says to - Adam entus she was an
impediment and I needed her out of the
way he says to Laura Ingraham I got her
out of the way this is very reminiscent
of when early in Donald Trump's
presidency remember when they were
denying any contact with Russians is
laughable now because of everything we
know but you had Trump denying contact
with Russians Mike Pence was denying
contact with Russians Don jr. denied it
Jeff Sessions famously denied it he got
caught lying and ended up having to
recuse himself on anything Russia
related when he was Trump's beleaguered
Attorney General now it seems
unbelievable that they were ever denying
it but at one point they were and then
you had Don junior tweet out oh yeah we
were in touch with Russians Russian
business people this Russian that
Russian but it's no big deal and
everything's fine it's deny deny deny
until it's too late and then they don't
and then they say well no I mean oh yeah
it happened but it's totally fine the
real story is some Democrat did some
other thing this time I don't actually
think it's part of a plan by Rudy
Giuliani it seems once again he's off
the reservation and this is exactly why
Rudy Giuliani was pulled off TV multiple
times early this year very early this
year we reported on it he blundered
badly in multiple interviews and he was
pulled off for a while more
cently he was pulled off again from Fox
News but he did speak to this reporter
last month he then was back on Fox News
last night and it is as ridiculous as
any of us imagined everything is the
opposite of what they tell us
Trump was rooting out corruption no
Trump wanted smears Jovanovic was
working on corruption and Rudy wanted
her out and got her out even though
that's what they had been denying I
really hope that Rudy Giuliani ends up
testifying in the Senate impeachment
trial it would be something amazing to
see people around Trump should try to
convince Trump that it would be great
for Rudy to testify that Rudy would just
do so great of course it's not true but
that might get Trump to tell Rudy to
show up and testify in the Senate
impeachment trial and then it would just
be an amazing situation to watch Rudy
Giuliani self-destruct
never mind Trump Trump said he would
consider testifying in the impeachment
trial I can't imagine he will be allowed
anywhere near the Senate trial by his
lawyers to the extent that they can
control him but we can always hope and
that would be I mean instant
self-incrimination let me know what
you're hoping for in the Senate
impeachment trial given that a
conviction is extremely unlikely on
January first we will be kicking off
2020 it's insane that it's already 2020
I remember when it was New Year's Eve
1999 and 2020 seemed comically far off
and we're just a couple weeks from it On
January 1 2020 we will have a crazy
membership special if you've been
thinking of it's an election year you
want to support alternatives to
corporate media get on our mailing list
by signing up for it at david pakman.com
subscribe to the newsletter and then on
January 1st you will get a beautiful
email a perfect email as Donald Trump
would say with an extremely
extraordinary membership special let me
know what you think about Rudy on Laura
Ingraham by sending me a tweet at D
Pakman we'll take a quick break and be
back right after this